imagine if your daily commute involved
tens of kilometers on these kinds of
roads driving this kind of vehicle
without any nearby service stations or
breakdown assistance for millions of
drivers in many parts of Africa this is
the norm since over 90 percent of
passenger cars are imported often used
they're just not designed for local
usage high import duties often compound
the problem sometimes doubling the price
of a car so most vehicles are either too
expensive or too unreliable for the
average consumer well-designed vehicles
are only part of the transport challenge
though for every 100 adults in Africa
less than five people actually own a
vehicle public transport is available
and in countries like Kenya it's often
run by local entrepreneurs using
minivans like this but in most rural and
peri-urban areas it's fragmented and
unreliable in more remote areas without
transport people have to walk typically
tens of kilometres to get to school or
collecting drinking water or buy
supplies from nearby markets bad roads
disparate communities low average income
levels and inadequate vehicles all
impair the transport system and
ultimately constrain economic output
despite this constraint the pan-african
economy is booming combined GDP is
already over two trillion dollars this
is a massive commercial and social
opportunity not a helpless continent so
why isn't there already something better
around the world automotive is core to
the manufacturing sector but in Africa
it's generally been overlooked by car
makers who have focused on larger
established markets and emerging
economies like India and China
this lack of industrialization which
itself creates a vicious cycle barrier
to the emergence of industry has caused
the dependence on imports there is a
supply demand disconnect with the vast
majority of automotive spending on the
continent today essentially funding an
international network of car exporters
instead of fueling the growth of local
industry it's entirely possible to solve
this disconnect though starting with
products that people actually want and
this is what motivated me to start
Mobius to build a vehicle in
Africa for Africa to us this meant
reimagining the car around the needs of
the consumer simplifying non-essential
features like interior fixtures and
investing in performance critical
systems like suspension to create
durable and affordable vehicles built
for purpose and built the purpose is
exactly where we started with our first
generation model Mobius - which was
designed as a really rugged low-cost SUV
able to handle heavy loads and rough
terrain reliably this launched in 2015
and we've now developed the next
generation version based on customer
feedback for high stress and the heavy
loading we engineered a sturdy steel
space frame to handle acute vibration
from rough roads we've ruggedized the
suspension for potholes and uneven
terrain high ground clearance was a
no-brainer and to make this something
customers could actually be proud to
drive in we designed an aspirational
body aesthetic underpinning all of this
we simplified or eliminated components
like parking sensors and automatic
windows wherever we could to keep costs
low and sell this half the price of a
five-year-old SUV in Kenya today the new
the new mobi is to launches in 2018
and while durable affordable vehicles
like this are vital a broader solution
to mobility needs to go further
over the last decade a transport centric
shared economy has connected people
across Africa with minivans auto
rickshaws and sedans it's just not
operated very effectively or efficiently
enabling better access to transport is
all about strengthening this public
transit network empowering local
entrepreneurs who already offer similar
services in their communities to operate
these services more profitably and more
widely with this aim we're taking human
centered design a step further and
developing a transport platform model
which enables owners to plug in
different modules like a Goods cage or
ambulance unit and run other services
like goods delivery or medical transport
as well as public transport
transportation services like this are
the fundamental driver of logistics
trade social services access to
education health care and employment the
transportation grid to physical
economies is akin to the Internet to
virtual economies and the impact of
increased mobility is only part of the
potential here since the late 1700s the
Industrial Revolution has catapulted the
devolve economies around the world into
thriving societies today manufacturing
is still the engine of economic growth
and stability even as new technologies
have inevitably transformed the way we
live
making stuff is important especially for
nation states wanting to boost
employment increase skills and reduce
import dependence but while few
countries can skip this industrialized
stage many have negligible manufacturing
output there are various reasons for
this but one reason is universal
hardware is hard so what are the
challenges to industry and how are you
approaching them the first issue many
people think of is a lack of skilled
labor in areas where access to good
primary and secondary education are
limited and employment opportunities are
scarce a small skill base is inevitable
but that doesn't mean it's immutable
there's an abundance of smart
hardworking and ambitious people in
Africa
obviously what's really lacking a good
jobs that offer a path not just to
employment but also professional growth
the first person we employed at Mobius
over six years ago is the mechanic named
Kazuya
gazonga who had gone to school up to the
age of 18 and worked as an odd job
mechanic joining the company at the time
was a near-vertical learning curve but
he rose to the challenge and with more
technical guidance from an expanding
engineering team he's grown over the
years to lead a group of mechanics in
R&D prototyping a thirst for learning
and the work ethic to step up to a
challenge our values we now recruit on
pairing an8 values like this with
on-the-job training and systems has
strengthened our skill base this works
really well on the production line where
work can be systematized around clear
procedural instructions and then
reinforced through training in our
experience it is possible to build the
skilled workforce and we plan to hire
hundreds more people using this approach
a second challenge is a lack of
suppliers in countries like Kenya there
are only a handful of automotive
suppliers manufacturing parts like
electrical harnesses seats and glass
it's a burgeoning group and without much
demand from in the industry most of
these suppliers have no impetus to grow
we've worked hard with a few of them to
develop the capacity to consistently
manufacture components with the quality
levels we need like this supplier in
Nairobi who were helping to reduce the
production cost of metal brackets and
improve their ability to build
conformant parts to our engineering
drawings supplier development is
standard practice in automotive globally
but needs to be applied from the ground
up with a vast majority of local
suppliers to properly bolster the
ecosystem and as production volumes rise
these supplies can employ more staff
invest in better equipment and continue
to develop new manufacturing techniques
to further increase output building up
skills and suppliers are not the only
hurdles to local industrialization but
they're good examples of how we think
about the challenge you see we're not
just reimagining the car we're
reimagining our entire value chain none
of this has been easy and we're only
just getting started but once African
industry starts to scale the potential
is huge better products costing less
built locally together creating millions
of jobs frugal innovation offers a path
to economic acceleration across many
industries and the future of this
continent depends on it the Africa to
point naught I believe in can apply
locally relevant design and a
commitment to solving its industrial
challenges to create a more connected
more prosperous future not just for the
privileged few but for everyone thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]